we have a voicemail number that you can
call whenever you please that number is
219
to david p here is a very interesting
voicemail weighing in
about donald trump's weaponization of
soup which we covered yesterday take a
listen to this hey david
um i just wanted to call in because i
thought of a little theory that i want
to get your thoughts on
yeah so as you know like trump has
recently begun
talks of like the weaponization of soup
in bag and canned form right and i think
that might just be
why he was so concerned about the
cupboards being bare
when he got into office right because
you know like we were out of bullets
the cupboards were bare like we were
completely defenseless basically
yeah exactly like no no cans i i would
wager no
no bags of sue yeah this is interesting
you know donald trump has been using
this phrase that when he took over from
barack obama the cupboards were bare
and it's weird to talk about cupboards
but where do people
keep cans of soup they typically keep
them in cupboards and maybe what donald
trump meant was
that soup cans which he now has made
clear he considers weapons in that weird
rant yesterday
the cupboard had no cans of soup that
is absolutely crazy but it makes about
as much sense as everything else that
donald trump says so i'm glad you're
thinking uh
to to our viewer who called in we have a
great bonus show for you today nancy
pelosi has handed trump
a gift and i'm going to tell you what
that is hoboken
is going to be suing fossil fuel
companies over
flooding saying it is a climate change
issue
and i am going to give you the latest
updates on the census i had some
interactions recently with census
workers
safe ones wearing masks of course all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com